À quelques kilomètres à peine
du centre de la capitale,
de rares indications que le pays
traverse un deuil national.
Dans ces rues, la vie continue
avec ses hauts et ses bas,
particulièrement ces jours-ci.
Au Royaume-Uni, l'inflation a
augmenté de 10 % en un an. C'est
le taux le plus élevé de tous
les pays du G7. Lese
font particulièrement sentir
dans des quartiers comme
celui-ci dans le sud de Londres,
où le tiers de la population vit
sous le seuil de la pauvreté.
Les besoins des gens du coin,
Solomon Smith les connaît bien.
Cinq jours par semaine,
son organisme distribue environ
150 repas chauds dans des
quartiers défavorisés. S'il dite
royale, Solomon Smith ne peut
se permettre de prendre congé
le jour des funérailles.
Lundi, il parcourra comme
d'habitude les quartiers
défavorisés du sud de Londres
pour distribuer de la nourriture
Férié ou pas, de nombreux
Londoniens dans le besoin auront
faim.
Dans ces quartier
la relation avec la couronne est
parfois compliquée.
Althea Smith, l'ancienne
mairesse de l'arrondissement
Southwark, explique que de
nombreux résidents sont des
descendants venus d'Afrique ou
ïbes; plusieurs
anciennes colonies dont
certaines ont toujours des
liens avec la Monarchie,
et où on évoque encore les
tions qui devraient
être versées pour les impacts de
ce passé colonial.
"Ces pays sont pauvres,
la Grande-Bretagne devraitleur ,
dit-elle.
Des revendications qui n'ont
pas empêché Althea Smith
d'attendre plusieurs heures pour
se recueillir devant le cercueil
d'une reine qu'elle respecta
♪ ♪ ♪
Si pour plusieurs dans
le quartier les cérémonies n
sont pas au coeur des priorités,
l'immense couverture médiatique
rend les événements difficiles à
ignorer.
Ce barbier a bien sûr vu
les images des kilomètres
d'attente pour accéder à
Westminster.
Impossible toutefois pour l
de s'absenter plusieurs heures
pour participer aux hommages;
la réalité d'un Royaume-Uni qui,
deuil royal ou non, n'a pas
le luxe de s'offri
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, à